ladies and gentlemen I hope you had a
good time we did now it's time for me to
ride off into the sunset there you go a
little something for yourself where
Thanks thanks very much
the reason the horse my new movie opens
June 12th is called city slickers
there's a billion people watching one of
my nuts good night everybody
the 63rd annual Academy Awards brought
to you by
today chevrolet who invites you to see
why more people are winning with the
heartbeat of America and JC Penney where
fashion comes to life
continental thanks the Academy was
selecting it to provide transportation
carbonating taking off with a new look
and a continuing commitment to give the
best performance in the air
Dilton which has invested over a billion
dollars to raise the standard of hotel
excellence is pleased to have provided
accommodations for the Academy Awards
Hilton Hotels & Resorts
for Oscar and the 63rd annual Academy
Awards this is Charlie O'Donnell
speaking
this is Ted Koppel later tonight on
Nightline let's see you live overseas
and the only thing you knew about
America were shaped by Hollywood movies
that view of the US might be pretty
warped tonight
well hello this is Rick Dees and tonight
join Golden Girls Betty White sexy
Yankee Steve sax and hot music from
Cathy Dennis into the night late night
tonight
all the eligible Academy members are
asked to vote for nominations for Best
Picture other nominations are voted by
members who are specialists in each
field winners are decided by vote of the
entire membership only members who
attend special screenings may vote in
the documentary short films and foreign
language categories results of the
secret voting are known only to the
independent accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse until the sealed envelopes
are opened on the air